the formula for NCR is n factorial
divided by R factorial times n minus R
factorial what is this this is the
formula for combinations but it is not
the best way to understand it and what
is NPR it's n factorial over n minus R
factorial and this again is not the best
way to understand permutations in many
books and videos you would be asked to
use this formula if we have to select
our things out of N and we would be
asked to use this formula if we have to
arrange our things out of n I can assure
you that if you understand just these
two formulae you will never really
understand permutations and combinations
there's only one thing you should
understand well if you wish to master
this topic and that's counting if you're
able to count well then the topic of
permutations and combinations will be a
walk in the park
of course the counting will not be as
simple as counting on your fingers it's
a little more advanced but don't worry
counting is easy let's say we have three
pens and two markers every item is
distinct no two items are the same
here's your first question based on
counting in how many ways can we pick
any one items from these five understand
the question well in how many ways can
we pick any one item from three pens and
two markers in how many ways do you
think we can do this look at it
logically we can either pick the first
pen we can call it P one or the second
pen or maybe the third pen or maybe we
pick a marker the first one or the
second one we kept saying or this or
this or this and so on you can see that
there are five ways
in which we can pick any one item and
how do we get a five three ways in which
a pen can be picked plus two ways in
which your marker can be picked five
ways in all this is the first rule of
counting or or always means addition
first pen or the second pen or the third
three ways in which a pen can be picked
and similarly two ways in which your
marker can be picked or always means
addition now let me ask you another one
in how many ways can we pick one pen and
one marker one pen and one marker tell
me what you think we have to pick a pen
and a marker in how many ways can we
pick a pen we pick either the first or
the second or the third
now having picked one pen we need to
pick a mocker
maybe after picking the first pen we
pick the first marker or maybe after
picking the first pen we pick the second
marker so one way is P 1 M 1 and another
is P 1 M 2 or maybe we pick P 2 and then
M 1 or P 2 and M 2 in all we can see
that there are six ways in which we can
pick a pen and a marker which are the
six ways P 1 M 1 P 1 M 2 P 2 m 1 P 2 m 2
P 3 M 1 and P 3 M 2 and how did we get a
6 3 ways times two ways multiplication
and is another rule of counting it
always means multiplication one pen and
one marker three ways multiplied by two
ways one pen or one marker three ways
plus two ways if you understand these
two rules of counting trust me
you will be able to solve most problems
based on permutations and combinations
and this is nothing new
I am sure you have used this many times
in life
look at this picture how many circles do
you see hideout you counted each circle
instead of counting each circle you
would have noticed that there are six
columns and four rows because it's ant
the number of circles will be 6 x 4 24
and all
don't forget the two basic rules and is
multiplication or is addition the topic
of permutations and combinations is not
liked by many students and maybe you as
well so we have covered as many topics
and examples as we can and I can assure
you that if you watch all our videos
based on this topic you will master the
concepts so take some time go through
our sessions and you will realize how
simple this topic is